the day that thoughts invented writing
samus warned him that he discovered a
drug that would make people lose touch
with themselves if you're still watching
you took thoughts pill and saw for
yourself the effects it really had it
started with visual depictions of the
world pictographs signs for ideas and
thoughts ideographs then a
transformation from picture writing to
true writing with symbols that stand for
words logographs using those word
symbols to stand for similar sounding
words rebus then those sound-alikes
became syllable characters syllabaries
consonant characters objet
alphabets or even constant involves
syllables alpha syllabaries and if
things get really linguistic savvy
alphabets become all featural characters
grouped by their phonetic properties
along the way of writing how to deal
with tensions and take sides should it
represent meanings or sounds should it
benefit the reader or the writer contain
maximum information about every sound or
just enough to recognize the shape of a
word
should it be flexible and creative or
rigid and consistent how do physical
techniques shape it oh and who did it
first who did it best maybe you've
learned to make some sense out of the
chaotic noise of world writing systems
maybe you can appreciate some of the
problems each one solves the traditions
it captures the ambiguities it creates
or perhaps it's more comfortable just to
close your eyes and wake up back at home
looking at your familiar characters of
your familiar writing system plastered
across your favorite websites still
somehow you can't even look at that the
same way it's just one invention among
many in the long history of this
language technology we call writing
you